you've written music for this new film
Moana and you even wrote a song for the
rock yes now I've met the rock many
times interviewed him lovely guy what I
don't know anything about a singing
voice is he he's good well Garbo talks
it's very excited I wanted to throw some
good I thought you would enjoy his kids
don't know about Greta Garbo kids get
out there and hit the skinny on Garbo
see no cute you know he prepped for that
thing the way he preps for like a fast
and furious movie he came in he knew the
song cold I met him in Florida to sort
of talk him through it and he was
fearless III I figured out his vocal
range from watching his wrestling videos
[Laughter]
there was a while when when the rock did
a heel turn that's wrestling speak for
when like you're a bad guy for a little
while and he would pull out a guitar and
just make fun of whatever town he was in
he bill I can't wait to get out of
Chicago and so I just listened to those
videos and now like okay he sings
between here and here and then he just
like knocked it out of the park he
sounds great
you